Transcription: Matt Leedham
Relecteur: eric vautier
La misère sociale me révolte,
la misère sociale m'étouffe.
Elle est partout.
Derrière chaque façade.
Elle s'exprime cependant tout
particulièrement dans la rue.
J’étais à Paris cet été.
Je revenais de 10 jours de stage
effectués dans une ferme
d’agriculture biologique
dans le sud de la France.
En direction de Bruxelles,
je change de gare à Paris.
Ayant planifié mon trajet avec précaution,
j'ai du temps à tuer et j'ai faim.
Pas loin de la gare du Nord
se trouve la pizzeria Bari.
Elle a l'air un peu kitsch, mais les gens
qui y mangent ont l'air de se régaler.
Je décide de rentrer
dans le restaurant.
L’air est climatisé.
La luminosité est ténébreuse.
Je commande une pizza et une 50.
Et là,
alors que j’ai croisé
mes bras derrière ma tête
et allongé mes jambes profondément
sous la table - la journée a été longue -
une femme dans la cinquantaine,
d’origine caucasienne,
portant un jeans et un sweatshirt,
me demande de l’argent.
C’était la troisième personne
aujourd’hui.
La serveuse, apparemment habituée, la
chasse sans y prêter réellement attention,
d’un vilain revers de la main,
comme si elle essayait de lui
envoyer de l’eau imaginaire.
Gêné,
je range mes bras et mes jambes,
je me tasse sur moi-même,
ne sachant pas quoi faire.
La mendiante part
sans le moindre sou, dépitée.
Je la regarde partir.
Son jeans est moulant
et ses jambes sont squelettiques.
A ma gauche se situe
un amoncellement de poubelles.
Elle s’y rend, résignée.
Pendant ce temps-là, ma pizza
tant attendue arrive.
Son plat arrive également.
Je porte à ma bouche la pâte, la
mozzarella, le basilic et la sauce tomate.
Elle pense à la sienne, un sandwich
croqué enrobé de cellophane.
Je mords ma pizza,
je mâche et elle aussi.
Et là, tout d’un coup, j’ai une envie
irrépressible de vomir,
mais j’avale et elle aussi.
Elle continue, nonchalante,
son chemin.
Sans destination précise, errant dans les
rues de Paris entre richesse et pauvreté.
Je n'ai plus faim.
Mon estomac est tout retourné.
Une autre femme arrive,
plus jeune cette fois-ci.
Elle a la trentaine, maghrébine,
encore plus affamée,
ses joues sont creusées,
son regard éperdu et plein de tristesse.
Elle me demande de l'argent.
Je lui réponds que je n’ai
malheureusement pas de liquide.
Elle est déçue, mais pas surprise,
elle s’apprête à continuer sa route.
Je la rappelle vite et je lui
propose de terminer ma pizza.
Des étincelles dans ses yeux.
Après avoir fait mille courbettes, elle
croque à pleines dents dans mes restes.
Elle dit :
« Ça faisait longtemps que je n’avais pas
mangé quelque chose d’aussi bon. »
Gêné, je ne savais pas
trop quoi lui dire.
J’aurais aimé la prendre dans mes bras
et lui dire que tout irait bien
et qu’il ne faut pas qu’elle s’en fasse,
qu’elle mangera bientôt à sa faim.
Mais rien n’y fait, je n’y fais rien.
Ça n'aurait pas été vrai.
Lorsqu’elle a terminé la pizza,
elle m’a encore une fois remercié,
puis elle est partie,
nonchalante, comme la femme squelettique.
Rien n’a changé.
Elle regarde avec commisération deux
démunis qui sont en train de fouiller
les mêmes poubelles que la quinquagénaire,
mais ils repartent bredouilles,
les maigres restes ayant déjà été vidés.
Je règle l’addition, j’endosse mon sac,
le train m’attend.
Plein de pensées trottent dans ma tête.
J'embarque.
Les sièges sont en cuir.
J’allume mon ordinateur
et je me connecte au Wi-Fi.
Deux heures à tuer dans le train
et l'envie de vomir persiste.
Je regarde différentes données.
C'est indubitable.
La France, et plus généralement l'Europe,
est en pleine crise sociale.
Il y a une paupérisation
des classes sociales inférieures.
Autrefois, les plus pauvres
travaillaient à l'usine.
Désormais, ils sont employés
par des grandes multinationales.
Livreurs, chauffeurs, le capital a réussi
à les opprimer et à les aliéner.
Ils n’ont pas de vacances payées,
pas de sécurité sociale.
Ils ont des revenus avoisinant
le SMIC, sinon moins.
Vivant dans des blocs, des HLM,
leurs fils et filles n’ont pas
les mêmes chances de réussite sociale.
Certains finiront dans la rue, d'autres
derrière les barreaux, d'autres en HP.
D'autres prendront la place de leurs
parents, mais peu réussiront.
Ils ne sont pas certains d’avoir à manger
sur la table en rentrant chaque soir
à la maison.
Les plus chanceux travaillent en tant que
caissier, rayonneur, infirmier,
ouvrier agricole ou du bâtiment.
Quoi qu’ils aient une sécurité sociale,
eux aussi touchent le SMIC.
Ayant grandi dans un milieu
socio-économique privilégié,
les concepts de classes, de faim et de
pauvreté m’étaient relativement abstraits.
C’était jusqu’à ce que je me rende
compte de quelque chose.
Des personnes qui me sont très proches,
même si loin d’être dans le besoin,
n’avaient pas la même situation économique
que la mienne
et j’avais du mal à le réaliser.
Souhaitant me faire de l’argent
pour partir en vacances,
j’ai postulé à divers jobs étudiants.
Je me suis fait embaucher
dans une pépinière.
J'ai rencontré des collègues vivant dans
une réalité parallèle à la mienne.
Nous étions pareils.
Mais nos vies ne l’étaient pas.
Tous avaient des histoires différentes
et ça m’a intéressé.
Qu’importe leurs origines,
tous avaient un point commun.
Ils sont nés dans la classe
sociale du prolétariat.
Comme s'ils étaient enchaînés
à leur condition.
L’été dernier,
un de mes proches m’a invité
à travailler avec lui
pour que je me rende compte
des réalités dans lesquelles nous vivions.
Mais aussi et surtout pour que
je passe du temps avec lui.
Et j’ai accepté.
J’ai passé une partie de mes vacances
à travailler avec lui dans les champs.
J’ai essayé de suivre son rythme de vie,
celui des ouvriers agricoles.
Je vais vous résumer nos journées.
Réveil à 4h30, départ à 5h15,
arriver à l’entrepôt à 5h55,
départ aux champs à 6h.
A 9h, il fait déjà 30 degrés.
L’implantation se situe dans une cuvette.
Aucune pause n’est autorisée, à part celle
de midi qui ne dure qu’une heure.
Le travail reprend à 13h
et ne termine qu’à 16h.
Le patron veut qu’on fasse
une heure supplémentaire.
La journée se prolonge une heure,
on part à 17h, on est en retard.
Sa fille l’attend à la sortie de la
maternelle depuis bientôt une heure
et j’ai mal au dos.
On arrive chez lui.
Il fait le ménage, la cuisine, se douche,
s’occupe de ses enfants, joue avec eux.
Tout ça pendant que je dors, car je n’en
peux plus, je suis physiquement exténué.
Tandis que lui accélère la cadence,
sa femme arrive.
Elle a travaillé aussi toute la journée
et elle est contente de retrouver
le ménage en ordre en rentrant.
Elle mange avec appétit.
Ce qu'il avait préparé était excellent.
Dans la soirée, on fait un jeu de société
qui se prolonge par un débat.
Il me dit : « Tu vois, on a tout fermé.
Plus rien ne fonctionne.
Tout le monde a travaillé
à partir de chez soi. »
Seuls les métiers essentiels à la survie
de la société
ont continué de tourner normalement,
de par leur nécessité naturelle.
Il me dit : « Je gagne 8 euros de l’heure
en tant qu’ouvrier qualifié.
Je n’ai aucune reconnaissance
de la part de la société. »
Quand un consommateur va à Carrefour
et qu’il achète sa salade 1,20 €,
il va pester, il va encore réussir
à dire que c’est trop cher.
Il ne se rend pas compte du travail
que c’est, des ressources que ça prend.
Je suis celui qui a fait
pousser cette salade.
Pourtant, comparativement au prix de
vente, je ne touche quasiment rien. »
Il me dit : « Je n’ai pas à me plaindre,
j’ai une bonne situation,
je gagne environ 1 300 euros par mois.
J’ai une femme et deux beaux enfants.
Mais il y a des gars, des galériens,
ils ne s’en sortent pas.
C'est la galère.
Un collègue est accro au jeu.
Il espère gagner le gros lot.
Il ne s’en rend pas compte,
il joue, il joue.
Tu sais, ils font de l’argent sur son dos.
Tout son salaire part à la FDJ,
et sa famille ne sait pas, il le cache.
Je ne dis pas qu’il faudrait
qu’on gagne plus que le patron,
puisque c’est grâce à lui qu’on a un job
et lui-même travaille plus que moi.
Mais quand même,
j’ai l’impression que je me suis
fait avoir quelque part.
Je ne peux pas me permettre
de partir en vacances
quand je veux ni où je veux.
Je n'ai pas les moyens d'offrir de
nouveaux vêtements à mes enfants.
On n'a pas les moyens.
J’aimerais bien retaper
la maison et la rénover.
Tu as bien vu qu’il y avait
des trous dans murs de la cuisine,
mais la banque ne veut pas
financer les travaux.
Ma femme, elle travaille dans le social,
elle essaie de redonner le sourire
à une jeunesse qui se sent abandonnée.
Tu sais, ça lui crève le cœur
de voir des gamins
se faire battre par leurs parents.
Ça lui crève le cœur de voir
des gamines se prostituer,
des jeunes se droguer pour s’évader.
Mais elle ravale sa chique et elle se bat
pour eux, elle les aide comme elle peut,
mais tu sais,
elle ne peut pas grand-chose. »
Et c’est au retour de chez lui que je vais
à la pizzeria dont je vous ai parlé.
Un message d'alerte me signale que nous
arrivons bientôt à destination.
Je me réveille.
Les messages qu’il m’a fait passer restent
profondément ancrés dans ma mémoire.
Je me dis qu’il y a quelque chose
qui ne tourne pas rond.
La pandémie a relevé des fractures
dans nos sociétés
et a creusé le fossé plus que jamais
entre les plus riches et les plus pauvres.
Depuis mars 2020, les politiciens parlent
de reconstruction sans cesse,
parlant du jour d’après,
d’un retour à la normale, mais...
je n’ai pas envie
de ce retour à la normale.
Je n’ai pas envie de revoir cette femme
dans la rue en train de crever de faim.
Je veux que la société ait
un nouveau souffle,
qu’elle ait un objectif commun :
le bien-être des peuples.
Nous avons accumulé assez de richesses
pour que plus personne ne meure de faim,
ni ne souffre de sa condition.
Alors pourquoi se développer à outrance
alors que nos bases sont si fragiles ?
Je ne dis pas qu’il faut tout changer
ou que tout est à jeter
parce que ce n’est pas vrai.
Il y a du beau dans la société.
Seulement, je propose que nous allions
vers une mondialisation alternative
où la coopération remplace la compétition,
où le dirigeant ne confond pas plateforme
politique avec foire d’empoigne.
Il est temps de s’interroger
sur la question du progrès
et de la remettre en question.
Où voulons-nous aller ?
Progresser pour faire quoi ?
La réponse se trouve en vous.
Elle bouillonne dans vos tripes.
Lorsque vous l’aurez discernée, agissez !
Nous le devons pour notre prochain.
Je vous encourage à voter, à manifester,
à penser, à réfléchir, à débattre,
aussi et plus que tout,
à rencontrer et à interagir
avec des personnes qui, de prime abord,
ne vous ressemblent pas,
mais qui, au fond, partagent avec vous
un lien des plus profonds,
l’Humanité.